stop by some local galleries whoops all
right well thanks for sticking out till
the end thanks for the organizers for
inviting me so before I tell you the
problem that we set of problems away
we studied I should say this joint work
with Neha Gupta is here in the audience
and Roy Schwartz is also here let me
tell you a simple problem that I want to
leave you with and you know there's one
thing you you should take back think
about this this nice simple problem I
think is very cute
and it's reflective of the kinds of
problems that we study in this world
okay so so you all know about the
minimum SD card problem right basic
problem take a graph divided into two
pieces such that s belongs to the first
piece T belongs to the other piece if
our cut is s s bar we're interested in
minimizing the number of edges also from
one part of the other undirected yeah
okay
now let's ask the following question
instead of summing up all of the edges
that go across from one part to the
other what if we pay attention to the
edges in the cut that are incident on
every vertex okay so let's look at a
particular vertex V and let's look at
how many of the edges incident on we
participate in this cut okay what if we
want to make sure that every vertex is
well cut no nope no edge no vertex has a
lot of its edges parts been in the cut
so that gives us the following objective
minimize overall cuts the maximum over
all the vertices in the graph of this
quality simple variation on the
classical SD card problem with a local
objective of vertex wise objective
instead of a global objective so if you
think of the cut as being a vector that
tells you for every vertex how many
edges incident on that vertex are cut
usual objective is just summing up all
the entries of the vector I'm saying
what happens if you want to minimize the
maximum entry the island for any dot so
how well do you think this problem can
be approximate just curious very well
okay well the short answer is we don't
know but we'll we'll give you some
partial answers in this talk okay
this is one problem I want you to take
back this should be the problem okay let
me tell you how we got to this question
so we actually we started thinking about
a certain problem called correlation
clustering it's a very simple problem in
this problem you have a bunch of
vertices you have edges these edges are
of two types you have positive edges
which indicated the two endpoints are
similar and you have negative edges that
indicate that the two endpoints are
dissimilar so you have a graph with
edges annotated with these positive and
negative labels what you like to do is
to cluster the the graph so that similar
edges end up inside clusters and these
dissimilar negative edges end up across
clusters and they may not be a
clustering that actually gets every
accurately you want to minimize the
number of disagreements or another
version is you might want to maximize
the number of greement so just to drive
this point home here's a particular
clustering these are mistakes because
they're positive edges that are actually
going across clusters these are also
mistakes because they're negative edges
that are inside clusters okay so it's a
very nice simple problem one thing
that's nice about this problem is that
the number of clusters is not fixed a
priority the goal of the of the
algorithm is to find whatever number of
clusters are appropriate for the given
input okay and this very nice question
was introduced by Bansal Blum and Chawla
in 2002 so it's been a while now 15
years and they were interested in in
some applications in machine learning
where you have let's say a bunch of
entities that are referred to in
documents you'd like to be able to
cluster them to figure out which
entities are really the same person the
same entity but the input to the problem
comes from a machine learning classifier
that gives you judgments about whether
or not it things two things are similar
or not okay so you know there are
various settings in which this problem
has been studied one is the complete
graph where all edges are labeled with
similar and dissimilar so one thing
that's that's very easy to see is if
there's a perfect clustering if there
indeed is a clustering with no mistakes
it's very easy to find it okay you just
take the connected components of the
green edges and that gives you your
perfect clustering in general of course
you are noisy information and perfect
clustering may not be possible whenever
you have a structure like this which is
a triangle consisting of two similar
edges and one dissimilar edge no matter
how you cluster it you got to make a
mistake okay you can't put them all in
the same cluster you can't put them in
different clusters you can't put two of
them in one cluster of one outside
either way you're going to make one
mistake okay and in general you might
have a number of such such things okay
so you know if perfect clustering exists
is easy to find it I said that the
challenge is what do you do if there's
no perfect clustering okay and there are
two kinds of versions of the problems
that have been studied as I said
minimize the number of disagreements
another one is to maximize a number of
agreement so let me just give you a
brief run-through of some of the things
that we know about the problem for
complete graphs this Venus a series of
work starting with the buncher Blum
Chawla paper and currently the best
known algorithm is a two point zero six
approximation due to Chawla at all a
very interesting question there's a
natural LP relaxation for this in fact
we'll see a very similar LP for our
problem there's integral D gap of two
and the question is you know it's to the
right answer and these guys come
tantalizing close to Hunt's to answering
that question
the problem with general graphs is as
hard as multi-cut turns out it actually
encodes multicart and similar graph
partitioning problems there's a log and
approximation for this dude over I do a
bunch of different authors on the
hardness side we know that it's a px
hard okay so we can't get beyond the
constant factor all right I'm not gonna
be saying much about the agreement
maximizing a riemann problem let me just
tell you what the results are just for
completeness so for complete graphs is a
pitas again from the original paper or
bun so at all and for general graphs
there is 0.76 6 approximation this uses
or this SDP random hyperplane rounding a
slight generalization of that and it's
also known to be a px are okay so that's
sort of the these results for
correlation class okay
you know this general correlation
clustering problem where you know you
have a subset of of the edges or you
might have weights on the edges actually
captures more general graph cut problems
so it captures minimum SD card'
multi-way cut multi-cat so it's a fairly
it's a very nice framework to study
these problems for example you know if
you wanted to encode minimum SD card you
know yours your graph the the plus edges
are indeed just these edges in the
instance and to encode the fact that s
and T need to be separated you just put
a minus edge with a super-large weight
okay so there you really have to
separate these guys the question is how
many of
of the of the positive edges do you need
to separate through the nice it's a nice
framework that captures a lot of the the
graph problems that we know and love
alright so I'm going to talk about these
clustering problems with local
objectives
instead of global objectives okay going
back to the first problem that I spoke
about you know these wrongs we usually
sum up the number of errors that we make
what if we were interested in minimizing
the worst error over all the vertices
okay that's the kind of objectives that
we'll talk about and I'll talk about if
I have time I want to talk about our
results for complete graphs as well as
our algorithm for general graphs I'll
say a little bit about the proof maybe
if we have time we'll see I'll give you
a I'll give you some open problems okay
so you know as I said usually for these
problems we think about a global
objective where we're summing up the
number of mistakes what if instead we
say we want to minimize the worst
mistakes over all the vertices okay and
that's the local kinds of objectives
that we'll be talking about so these
these kinds of problems were introduced
by recently by polio million Kovac in
2016 this last year and they were
interested in correlation clustering
with local guarantees because they you
know okay so just to give you this to
belabor the point here are two
clusterings of the same same instance
from a global perspective this these
make the same number of mistakes but
this one is little better than this one
because in this one this particular
vertex has two mistakes whereas this one
has three mistakes
so the local objective obviously it's
different from our global objective so
Pulliam William Kovac introduced this
set of problems and they were interested
in in a very practical motivation they
were in detecting communities with this
in this situation where there's no
antagonist and whatever they meant by
this was there are no vertices there are
no entities that disagree with their own
cluster too much okay they were also
interested in using this for
recommendation systems where the number
of mistakes that that you make for a
vertex is related to the quality of the
recommendations that you'd be providing
to this particular the person who's
encoded by that vertex and so in order
to make sure that nobody is too badly
off you want to try to minimize optimize
this local objective rather than a
global objective okay
what's nice about these you know this
local version of correlation clustering
is that it actually encodes a whole
bunch of other problems like this min
max SD card that I defined I mean max
multi card min max multi maker so you
know our addition this was twofold one
was to understand the approximate any of
these problems but also it seemed that
these are very natural variants of well
studied optimization problems if for
some reason haven't really been studied
before to the best of our knowledge
people haven't really looked at these
questions before and so we were curious
to see how well we can do for these okay
so that's the toaster problems are we
talking about so let me tell you what's
known so it's known that you know this
problem for complete graphs and hence
with general graphs is np-hard polio
Ellen Kovac gave a constant factor
approximation for complete graphs yes
yes always the same okay and that's the
status status of the problem can you
also give in to gravity graph for
general graphs all right so so we're
going to give a simpler and a more
better constant fact
algorithm for complete graphs I'll give
you an algorithm for general graphs
which will answer this question somewhat
and I think that's all I have time for
okay so the algorithms themselves are
very simple I think I if if I do this
properly I should have time to walk you
through some of the main some of the key
ideas in the analysis I just want to
introduce these problems say that these
are nice fun problems think about and
there are some very basic questions in
here that would be nice to have more
people thinking about them okay all
right
so how do we get an algorithm for
complete graphs we're gonna use an LP we
have to write this is the workshop and
continuous room the speed optimization
with continuous relaxation okay so we're
gonna set up a linear program which
measures the number of mistakes that we
make at every vertex okay and in this
linear program we're gonna encode the
partition the cut by a zero one metric
okay so at this a distance of one
indicates that these two guys are
partitioned distance of zero means that
these two guys are on the same cluster
so in order to measure the mistakes at
you we've got to sum up over all the
edges incident on you and say which of
the plus edges have a distance of one
which of the - I just have a distance of
zero that's always coming up that's the
number of mistakes that we make at you
and now we want to minimize the maximum
on these deals okay because these these
distances duv have to be a have to be a
relaxation of a clustering the standard
way in which we do that is we say that
this is a metric it satisfies triangle
inequality okay so that's a relaxation
it's just it's a very simple relaxation
so this kind have been used for
correlational trust ring okay
all right so how do we use this for for
our local problem so you know one hurdle
you run up against is that there are
many algorithms of correlational
trusting many different approaches and
quite a few of them I've used
randomizer are named okay it's great it
works really well for global objectives
but very hard to make it work in fact it
seems impossible to make it
the local so you know these randomized
learning approaches do very well from
the global perspective but they could
have you know individual vertices could
be very badly off okay all right so we
give a deterministic algorithm a very
simple one let me tell you what it is so
you know we solve our LP we get our
distance function and now we're gonna do
the following we're gonna look at a 1/7
ball around vertices and pick that
vertex that has the maximum number of
vertices in its 174 okay
and then we pick this guy and pick a
radius three seven something a little
less than half around it that's our
cluster take it out and recurse okay so
it's sort of a curious algorithm and
this algorithm actually gives you a
certain approximation okay I'll give you
a letter give you a flavor of the
analysis enough so that if you're really
interested you can go back and read it
or you know you could even reconstruct
it okay so we're gonna take the
algorithms cost and I remember there's a
cost for every vertex we're interested
in minimizing the maximum guy we're
gonna we're gonna compare the mistakes
that we make at a particular vertex with
the mistakes of the LP main of that
vertex and bound it to show that they're
within a factor of seven of each other
okay and if we show that we're done all
right okay so you know what do we need
to worry about we need to worry about
mistakes and the mistakes could be you
know - edges that are sitting inside a
cluster of plus edges are going across
cluster okay now - you know one thing to
keep in mind is is the following if for
an edge the LP has already paid a lot
then we can afford to make a mistake on
this guy okay so plus edges where the LP
pay is more than one seventh very easy
to deal with
- edges where the LP pay is more than
one seventh very easier to deal with
it's the it's the edges where the lp
makes very few mistakes are we have
trouble with okay and those are the ones
that are really gonna bother us in the
analysis okay so you know that's that's
what you want negative edges inside the
cluster well remember that the radius of
our cluster was little less than half
okay so no negative edge that's
completely inside the cluster can have
distance that's close to one so any
negative edges inside the cluster the LP
has gotta have paid a lot for it at
least one seven so we're okay
okay that's not a problem okay that's
what you are the positive edge this this
one is a little more interesting so let
me give you a little flavor of how we
handles
again the long positive edges are easy
the short positive edges are the ones
that we have trouble with okay so I'll
give you one one case that you should be
worried about okay and this is what if
you have a vertex u that's sitting
outside here it has a lot of short
positive edges that are going inside
this cluster how could we possibly bound
the cost that we incur for that
particular vertex you okay what's more
troubling is that this vertex you could
accumulate cost for multiple iterations
of our algorithm every time we pull out
a cluster you could have additional cost
on this guy somehow we need to deal with
this okay all right so here's how we
deal with this we're gonna say well
let's look at all of these guys who are
in this one seventh ball okay there
could be number of these guys so all of
these blue guys here could contribute
one to use cost and this is a problem
well remember the way in which we picked
our initial cluster was we said let's
pick that s star which has the maximum
number of guys when it's 1/7 the ball
okay and this is gonna save us now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna for each
of these blue guys we have one of these
purple guys okay and what we'll do is
we'll come look at this this edge UV but
also this edge UV star now this edge UV
star is kind of in a No
laughs okay it can't be very small and
it can't be very large
it can't be close to zero it can't be
close to one no matter what the LP is
going to have paid a lot of cost for
this UV storage okay if it's a plus edge
or it's a minus edge the LP is going to
have paid a large cost for this and
that's going to save us okay
so for every mistake that we made
there's something else that the LP paid
a large amount okay so that's
essentially the analysis all right let
me switch gears and say how do we handle
general graphs okay so we chime graphs
have a problem there's a very simple
example that has a large integrality gap
for general graphs you just take a cycle
consisting of positive edges one
negative edge give weight in a distance
one over N to each of these guys and one
minus one over end of this guy in a
fractional sense every vertex has two
over n mistakes incident on L but of
course the integral we have you may at
least one mistake
okay so we're gonna do a simple
modification okay but now just think of
all the costs as being either if the
edge exists the cost is one okay we want
to deal with general weights but let's
not worry about that let's just take max
of the LP cost and one use that as our
lower bar and we show that this lower
bound is within a factor of root end of
the right answer okay okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell you how you got a root an
approximation based on this robot okay
so we solve the same our P as before
well we can handle arbitrary weights but
right now just think of our unit weights
for simplicity okay all right any any
questions yeah maximal being one yeah
because I made this assumption of the
way it so on okay since everyone's
worried about weights let me just tell
you you can handle general weights very
easily we're gonna guess the maximum
weight as that that you need to make a
mistake on okay and once you throw that
in you can you can come up with the
bottom all right so with always LP now
which we have very very modest expected
we only want a root and approximation
okay now the only edges that we need to
be worried about are the edges for which
the LP pay is very little less than one
over root n all the other edges we're
fine with making a mistake okay so if
you have a positive edge whose length is
more than one over root n which is gonna
remove it yeah we could be gonna forward
to make a mistake on this guy if you
have a negative edge whose length is
very close to one we could remove it
because you know we can afford to make a
mistake on this guy so what are we left
with we're only left with edges that the
LP length is less than one over root n
positive edges and negative edges where
the distance is 1 minus 1 over root ok
very close to 1 we're going to work with
this graph okay these are the
problematic edges now what we're going
to ensure is that in fact all the all
these long negative edges we're
definitely going to separate their
endpoints for sure
how does I'm going to proceed in that
way and now we want to somehow make sure
we don't make too many mistakes on these
short positive edges okay so let's look
at one such pair that's separated by
this long negative edge let's look at
our graph of these short positive edges
let's ignore the LP lengths let's just
think about the graph length shortest
path in the graph
so by design you know the the shortest
part to get from here to here has length
about root n right by design because
each remember each positive edge had LP
distance 1 over root n the negative edge
at LP distance very close to 1 so we
just do a breadth-first search okay do a
breadth-first search from this guide or
this guy and look at you know the
lengths the the number of vertices in
each layer in the first half of the bed
first search find 3 layers such that
each of these layers has less than about
root n vertices you can show very easily
that that's such a such 3 layers must
exist and now choose your cluster to be
everything up to and including the first
of these 3 layers and the claim that
this gives you a root an approximation
okay
alright it's not very hard to show you
know again you need to worry about well
we remove this cluster in this recursion
remaining graph okay how are they are to
show alright so you know what do we need
to worry about so you can convince
yourselves that this graph and this
method ensures that you know all the
negative edges that are very close to
one are never inside a cluster and the
reason that happens is because look you
know the way in which we designed our
cluster we took radius of slightly less
than half there's never going to be a
long negative edge in here
what it should be worried about somehow
is these positive edges how do you make
sure the positive mistakes are no more
than root n okay so well first of all
these guys who are inside here never
have any of their positive edges being
cut no problem
these guys who are on this boundary in
this first of these three layers they
could have their positive edges being
cut but where do these positive I just
go to well these positive I just just go
to the
next layer and we ensured that the next
layer has fruit n vertices no problem
okay now what about the guys who are
just outside well they could get
affected multiple times right so this
guy
some-something out here didn't get
picked it lost a whole bunch of its
short edges but this could happen over
and over and over again and this is the
problem right well not exactly
why remember for every guy who's in this
middle layer only vertices that it could
lose as neighbors or vertices here and
here okay in the future additional
mistakes that you will incur for this
guy are only you know these guys and
there are at most row ten of them okay
so for everybody who's just outside not
including our cluster we have a
guarantee the total number of mistakes
we're going to incur is Rutan all right
and so we're done so that's that's the
algorithm very simple algorithm in fact
this is the best algorithm we know for
this min max SD card okay all right I
actually walked through the analysis
this is exactly what I said now even
though I made the assumption that all
the distances are 1 all the weights are
0 or 1 you can actually generalize this
for general graphs ok it's not very hard
okay so open questions I think this is
one of the most dental icing open
questions how just how hard or how easy
is this min max SD card problem can you
get improved approximation algorithms
can you improve our seven can you
improve our root and root n is the one
that we have no idea I've no idea that
root n is really the right answer in
terms of lower ones the only result we
know is okay so we know of hardness for
for this min max problem on for general
correlation clustering we it's been
reported to us that there is NP hardness
for min max SD card although I haven't
actually seen the manuscript
I don't really know that's it so the
problem is white oh okay it's a natural
problem I hope something some of you
will want to think about it thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]